foreign
how can we help
well first of all it's an honor to talk
to both you I I'm a big time regular fan
and listener and I really appreciate the
advice you give me whatever it be um
just asking me to differentiate between
my position and uh my wife's okay oh oh
boy this is great I'm gonna I'm gonna
come at it from Dino's perspective and
Rachel will come at it from your wife's
we'll see what happens hit us all right
I'll try to give you a synopsis now we
we are well as of 30 days ago we were
completely debt free we own our homes
congratulations
thank you thank you I even have a rental
house that it's 100 paid for amazing
Dino right yeah we think we're finally
do we really suffered to get to where
we're at and if all the beans and rice
as they say it's true I'm not at the
seven figure number but I'm I'm tracking
it down we're getting there what well
what I wanted to do is right so my
business is heavy into
um real estate and I have a fantastic
they call them a whale client he's like
you know he's a great great client and
he's responsible for a huge huge portion
of our business and long story short
he's invited us to attend um his party
the birthday party up in New York City
which is going to cost us a couple of
bucks now hold on hold on to give us the
full detail I gotta know how much is it
gonna cost you because I know this is
where this is headed well the thing is I
kind of left something out there we just
bought this we just bought it my wife a
car brand new
um and I anticipate on paying that thing
off you know in less than six months for
sure
um
you told us you were debt free well I
know as of 30 days ago
yeah I have to retract the screen for
about six months but uh but you don't
get to do that so now you you'll take a
loan out go to New York no you can't I
didn't
screen for
it's okay but you can't go to New York
you can't go it's gonna cost you a lot
you didn't answer my question how much
it was even gonna cost but you can't do
it do you not have cash in the bank do
you know to pay off this car yeah yeah
I've got I've got about 25 Grand in the
bank 15 in my savings and 12 or so in my
working account
um I I paid for the tickets already
um the you know it's gonna cost me about
3 000 more we're not going on a summer
vacation because Fort Myers got
destroyed so I'm kind of you know also
subtracting in by addition they're kind
of okay Dino we know what's happening
who what's the wife's position and
what's yours let's get to the drama
wants to go you want to go to New York
uh yeah I know he does but I want to
hear you say it that's part yeah I mean
he's not only is it going to be awesome
when he takes away yeah of course he of
course it is do you know fomo
Start Spreading the News Dino's leaving
today
hunker down she thinks we should hunker
down
a car now she's already riddled with
guilt over the car why didn't you go buy
a 25 000 car
I I bought a forty eight thousand
dollars
because that was she's been doing
without for so long
such a great guy Dino he got the truck
she got the the big one the nice truck
and so one and done though I've checked
that off the bucket list I won't ever be
asked from her to buy a car again
um but that's the deal you know well you
can go to New York if she sells the car
back to the dealer we make up the
difference
hey just throw a high fastball right
under Dino's chin and he's thinking
about it wow even though I could pay
this thing off for real in six months
you know
um bro what do you want us to say you
you started the call saying I really
love the show you give me good advice
and you thought we were going to give
you a pass I thought you were going to
say hey dude you know you're you're you
know you could handle three G's you know
you know what I mean okay and here's the
deal could you sure but also there's a
discipline factor of like new you guys
put yourselves back in Financial hole
yeah yeah you got a car loan now and
it's like all right now everything's
focused on getting this car paid off
we're going 100 buy into that you know
it's it it's it's you know on the
negative side will it hurt my career
because this guy is in charge of no more
than she says it won't matter he didn't
care he's not like trust me but idino I
don't want this to hurt your feelings he
doesn't care if you don't show up he's
gonna be pretty happy with or without
you he's gonna be a New York party yeah
yeah yeah you're going to be homeless on
Netflix that's what's going on with the
microwave popcorn and your new 48 000
car just sitting in the garage you
should go watch the movie in the car
because I'm sure that's a DVD player
good call
I'm not going to New York is what I'm
saying what you're saying I think we
made it abundantly clear Dino oh Kenny I
thought you were gonna be a little bit
nicer to me hey Dino are you called the
Ramsay show yeah all all of our cars we
say beans and rice rice and beans you do
nothing until you're dead gets paid off
we got really quick though I do have to
go back or have so much fun with you
Dino did you say you already had paid
some of the money towards the the New
York whale trip
yes sir I um you know can you get it
back
well I can probably get a credit from
the airline I I had to come my company
paid for it and um you know it's already
booked how much left would be on the
trip uh if you if you what's the rest of
it
I figured it was like 500 bucks for the
tickets it wasn't all that much if they
give me a credit they might charge me a
hundred bucks a ticket so I'll have a
little bit of credit if you want yeah
but I'm saying how much more money would
you have to put towards the trip
probably 2500 you gotta do two hotels
yeah yeah 900 bucks a night for the
hotel and then no you know we're getting
up we're getting a private yacht tour of
New York you know they're taking us up
oh man Dino Dino I I gotta tell you I I
really want you to go see the whale
client I really want you to take a yacht
trip around New York City I mean that
sounds amazing but feels like you got to
have some pain in order to do this you
got to sell something maybe sell the car
hey I really would just sell that car
though y'all it's not worth it go ahead
and get rid of it it's depreciating
right now it's not worth it then go
watch she's gonna be okay in two years
so sell the car and go to New York then
go to New York tell them to buy that get
that whale Harpoon him getting to buy
something else and enjoy the yard pay
cash for the new car watch the DVD